and the spirit award for best
documentary
goes to
[ __ ] camp
my god thank you so much for this
incredible honor
it seems so fitting considering that the
film celebrates independent spirit
the spirit of the incredible disability
rights activists
who forged a community as teenagers in
1971
and then went forth built a movement and
changed the entire world
and we couldn't have told the story
across six years of my life and 51 years
of jim's life without the help of some
extraordinary people
first and foremost i want to thank
president obama and mrs obama
for their belief in us and for their
willingness to share
their platform their wisdom and their
love with this project and also
priya swami nathan and tonya davis the
gift that you brought to this project is
just extraordinary
um and i also want to thank netflix we
could not have had better partners in
blazing the trails that we needed to
blaze in order to make this film
fully accessible to the disability
community i'd also like to thank howard
gerdler our executive producer
who uh was with us so early on in the
project and
had such a huge impact um
and our editors um eileen meyer andy
gersch
mary lamson you brought such heart to
this project
and and talent that uh
was so so needed and so well
um i would be remiss if i didn't thank
the people that you see in this film uh
people are so instrumental
in the disabled civil rights movement
and this film was dedicated to them
the modern warriors and the disability
justice movement
and especially my fellow campers
and staff and counselors from camp
genned
who um when i was 15 set me on a course
of my life
that was so important and has been so
unbelievably far out
you